London is burning bright this weekend as
the switch is flipped on this year's
Lumiere London festival the work of more
than 50 artists from all over the world
is on display as they accentuate the
cityscape through several displays of
lights more than a million people are
expected to take in the sights Jonathan
Vigliotti shows us around
Lumiere London is a visual feast a
kaleidoscopic offering to the Bleak
Midwinter night and an Instagram Abul
buffet for those passing through for one
weekend the British capital becomes a
gallery for light all of it the
imagination of a group of international
artists their works vary from the
fantastic like Ronnie Bob owies
shimmering wheat fields and Miguel
chevaliers Lunar Oxford Circus
installation other works are anchored in
reality dan ruse and garg's water licked
at Kings Cross was inspired by the
world's rising sea-levels alamin owies
my light is your late a tribute to
Syrian refugees that moment of stopping
and just thinking for a second this is
all what I want art installations light
up more than 50 different locations
across the city Lumiere's creator helen
marriage says the ultimate goal is to
celebrate public space we feel like
these moments that we can create moments
of magic give the city back to its
residents and its visitors and a way to
forget the sunlight here goes out around
4:00 p.m.
for now flamingos flock in Chinatown and
illuminated umbrellas spin through the
streets until the lights go out on
Sunday
for CBS this morning Saturday Jonathan
Vigliotti London I need one of those
flamingos yeah I just love that light
festival it's so lovely